bagneux c'est la stupéfaction les
habitants et les voisins de la cité ont
appris que c'est dans un appartement
d'un des quartiers qui a été séquestré
ilan halimi dans les obsèques se sont
déroulées ce matin au cimetière de
pantin et spontanément des bougies ont
été déposées près de son lieu de travail
anouk burel vincent ferreira fermé en
mémoire dylan lit-on sur le papier les
commerçants du quartier n'ont pas eu le
coeur à travailler eux sont venus
spontanément apporté des fleurs des
bougies lire des prières sur le
boulevard voltaire à paris
c'est une véritable boucherie on est
révolté les commerçants ne veulent pas
parler je dis tout haut ce que je pense
à un animal on n'aurait pas fait ça le
jeune homme a été enterré dans la
matinée et l'arrestation des membres
présumés du gang soulage dans le
quartier je prends les choses avec
impatience et un vrai plaisir de danton
qu'ils ont été arrêtés ici la majorité
pense que l'enlèvement avait un
caractère antisémite
même si à ce jour l'enquète ne le
démontre pas au quartier des tertres à
bagneux où les interpellations ont eu
lieu les habitants n'en reviennent pas
le chef de gang habitait dans cet
immeuble
sa famille est effondrée ses voisins
atterré jusque jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
toujours vu comme ses enfants
disposeront enfants rien du tout marie
hélène amiable maire de bagneux ne cache
pas son émotion
je suis ému bien sûr c'est une situation
c'est une situation difficile pour une
ville et pour ses habitants bien
évidemment quand ils arrivent une chose
une chose d'une telle importance un tel
drame
dans la matinée les habitants ou appris
que le jeune ilan aurait été séquestrée
dans cet immeuble une rue calme dans une
cité sans problème